very terrifying moment on a busy street
in orlando when a driver saw a plane
falling from the sky watch
oh my god bro
holy
oh my god
unreal i don't want to bury the lead
everybody's okay
so raya collins said she started rolling
video on friday when she saw the plane
was flying really low it crashed through
this fence and into someone's driveway
local officials say the plane suffered a
mechanical failure the ntsb is
investigating the crash the pilot
survived with minor injuries lucky
looking very lucky ooh
yeah very very incredible it's always
amazing to me that people have their
cell phone ready to go i know i always
think the same thing so
the thing is always amazing to me is
that you can you can see some drivers
who are like i don't have time for this
time i gotta go they have plane landing
next year and they're like come on i
know i i think i'm like because i if i
saw something i'd just be like what is
going on but then if you're younger
you're probably your first instinct grab
the phone right